♪ Line up beside
your best friends. ♪
♪ Jump forward
and jump forward again. ♪
♪ I know a little direction
is all you need, ♪
♪ so follow my lead,
follow my lead. ♪
♪ We're dancing forward.
We're dancing back. ♪
♪ We're dancing up, down,
and sideways, ♪
♪ and that's a fact. ♪
♪ This dance can take us
to where we want to be. ♪
♪ What do we call this dance?
Directionality, hey! ♪
♪ Eyes up and raise
your hands high. ♪
♪ Take one step backwards
and clap them four times. ♪
♪ Let me see you
jumping around, ♪
♪ let me see you drop. ♪
♪ Let me see you freeze
when you hear the beat stop. ♪
[MUMBLES]
♪ Come together
and form a straight line. ♪
♪ Reach for the shoulders
of whomever you're behind. ♪
♪ Now to start to march. ♪
♪ Let the leader
control the speed. ♪
♪ Just follow their lead.
Follow their lead. ♪
♪ We're dancing forward,
we're dancing back. ♪
♪ We're dancing up, down,
and sideways, ♪
♪ and that's a fact. ♪
♪ This dance can take us
to where we want to be. ♪
♪ What do we call this dance?
Directionality. ♪
♪ We're dancing forward.
- We're dancing forward. ♪
♪ We're dancing back.
- We're dancing back. ♪
♪ We're dancing up, down,
and sideways, ♪
♪ and that's a fact.
- That's a true, true fact. ♪
♪ This dance can take us
to where we want to be. ♪
♪ What do we call this dance?
Directionality. ♪
♪ Helpsters! ♪
♪